Oh  it's hard to watch something you love  destroy itself to see it fall apart  disaster always feels so distant  detached someone else's struggle in some  faraway place it's not until it's in our  city and our doors that we realize how  fragile we are all of us all of this I  wouldn't hit when it came down it came  down hard  give me my family bad we fell we buried  ourselves and anger fear and the  instinct to survive I'm sorry  six  where's the dried sign please  the real truth is no one watched no one  saw wanted to see where you go tragedy  is invisible people turn away from it  and run from it if they can and it's  hard knowing that you belong here but  your purpose lies amongst all this pain  but someone's gotta be there to pick it  off to push back  but the first piece back together put us  all back together